the brain and body are intimately linked
if you want to improve your body do
something for your mind if you want to
improve your mind do something for your
body at a macro level it's clear that we
should all be getting that 150 to 200
minutes of Zone 2 per week or walking a
lot if you live in a big city you're
probably getting that but then also
getting your heart rate up to max heart
rate once a week doing some Sprint type
stuff in whatever format is safe for
your body some people it's swimming some
people it's rowing some people it's
running and then everyone should be
doing at least six sets of resistance
training per muscle group per week
minimum hard sets to failure okay maybe
maybe not to fill yeah probably and
especially the groups that have been
let's just say averse to weight training
right typically women older folks
although now more women weight train
because they understand that in the
absence of a lot of injected or
prescription anabolic hormones they're
not going to get enormous